for the last six months I've been
working on my own nft project we've put
hundreds of thousands of dollars in it
uh personally the whole team a million
plus we had an issue with um crypto Zoo
where our our lead developer uh took the
code that he made fled to Switzerland
actually fled to Switzerland and like
held it hostage for a million dollars
Eddie promised me you know five pursuit
of tokens and a billion dollars never
you never really never paid me this
reporter says Eddie's entire story is
fake
I'm not the bad guy here yeah yeah
there's some actual out there yeah and
I'm it's not me like I'm here to build
[Music]
welcome to part three so far we've
discovered fake orphans millions of
dollars stolen and a cast of sleep
characters but now it's time to put it
all together what is the truth and who's
to blame we're gonna start by going
through leaked text messages of the
crypto Zoo team to understand all of
their motivation then we'll go to
blockchain evidence and show Who Sold
what and finally we'll confront some of
the people responsible but before we can
do any of that we have to start in March
of 2021 six months before the token even
launched our four suspects Logan crypto
King Eddie and Jeff are in a group chat
discussing crypto Zoo which starts as a
copy of something else quote I like
imitating crypto kitties Jake the crypto
King says Logan replies I agree and
initially it wasn't called crypto zoo at
all it was called crypto pets and they
were gonna sell a pets token and pretty
early on it became clear this was all
about money how they were gonna sell
this thing to investors in fact crypto
King said he thought it was worth at
least 20 million dollars in only six
months saying the range is insane 20 to
210 million dollars it's beautiful
wherever we land Eddie jumped in at this
point and talked about how he could sell
the project as an investment to a friend
Matt Higgins saying quote he has to
spend that 350 million dollars somewhere
why not us and Logan says I love that
idea crypto King I'm in and of course
you have Jeff saying let's go so you can
see right there they wanted to sell this
game before it had even launched now
later Eddie amends the list of investors
and says quote investors will be garyvee
Todd Morley James altucher Ryan
Kavanaugh and others confirmed on my end
supposedly they had a hundred million
dollars of investment interest now I
actually went to some of these investors
and asked if this was true and the one
person who responded denied it Ryan
Kavanaugh quote nope not even a little
bit so this looks like it could be yet
another lie from Eddie Ibanez but either
way it looks like there was more issues
than just finding investors because the
team wanted to pre-sell tokens and not
everyone was sure it would be legal Jake
the crypto King mentions that quote if
we have a pre-sell it opens us up to SEC
issues and Jeff agrees and says don't
want to do anything that brings the SEC
eyeballs now not everyone wanted to be
so cautious though Logan argues everyone
does pre-sale with coins Eddie agrees he
says you absolutely can do it I have the
SEC down private and pre-sell and
honestly it was quite the Dilemma for
this team who wanted money you know do a
pre-sale make millions but you know you
have these potential legal issues don't
do it you make less money so crypto King
comes up with a middle solution he says
if we can't sell no pre-sale we can
still trade them in the liquidity pool
and this is the start of a new disaster
which takes a bit of explaining now just
so we're clear a pre-sale is where you
sell investors coins usually at a
discount before you've launched and then
when you launch you give them those
coins now like I said the team didn't
want to do that so what they did instead
was was they bought the tokens on the
open market right after launch but they
tried to get clever with it because they
didn't actually announce that they were
launching this coin at all they stealth
launched it on June 11th and didn't
announce this token through Logan until
August 18th meaning they had all that
time to silently buy up as much of the
supply at a steep discount as they
wanted and the idea here was that doing
this the team could get these tokens
extremely cheaply which is kind of like
a pre-sale but you know without all the
SEC troubles and crypto King makes this
clear on June 7th when he says quote
launch of the liquidity pool is where
huge money will be made because you get
in cheaper and then says we the team
begin buying out the liquidity pool once
the team has exhausted funds for the
liquidity pool buying we send the
contract address to friends family
investors who want to be able to get in
so obviously the plan is we buy first
then we give it to our close friends and
family and then maybe the public
eventually right and even the day before
crypto King reminds everyone quote Zoo
day is tomorrow I highly recommend
everyone get a few hundred to a few
thousand dollars in zoo when it goes
live it will likely tend to a thousand X
so that was their plan rather than doing
a pre-sale they were going to do this
stealth launch and hopefully get tokens
cheaply the same way but without all the
legal troubles or at least that was the
plan because on stealth launch day this
is where things first started to go
wrong for the team at first everything
seemed to go normal the team sat in a
circle and literally bought it out as
planned but the next day crypto King
says something odd quote a bot is
playing with our token kind of cool to
watch them work but he doesn't mention
who this bot is and he also says the
[ __ ] finished selling but doesn't
mention who that is now Jeff Logan's
manager replies upset he says how do we
prevent someone doing what they just did
again we went from 130 million to 26
million dollar market cap in two hours
it's not cool to watch Logan jumps in
yeah wait how did that happen and he
also says whatever how did anyone get
this token except for us and none of us
sold and I think actually this is
incredibly suspicious because the
application of what Logan's saying is
hey we tried to scheme this really well
we tried to all buy this without letting
anyone know how did this how did anyone
else figure out we were buying it right
and this is where a fight ensues that's
going to become really interesting
crypto King deflects the question by
saying my buyer pushed it back up to 40
million dollars and Logan says no bro F
your buyer explain to me what just
happened and how there were 30 token
holders and Jake tries to explain that
this was just Traders and Bots happening
to find the token but Logan says only
five of us knew about it Jake says well
many people chase volume and new tokens
and to some extent he's kind of right
but Logan replies cap he doesn't believe
it quote I can't be the only one who
thinks that's too incredibly convenient
like someone was tipped off
and and look no one's more critical of
Logan than me but as I'm reading these
texts I was kind of like agreeing like
yeah it does seem too nonchalant when
somebody's ruining your secret plot you
know what I mean because crypto King was
acting very strange he says we created
40 million dollars out of thin air this
is a success Logan replies this
nonchalance worries me F40 million it
was at 120 million which again it's all
about the money with these guys but
truth be told I did agree that crypto
King's attitude seemed strange in these
texts I mean he's not wrong that Bots
are a thing Traders are a thing but it
sounded like he didn't want anyone to
look into it so naturally I looked into
it and what I found surprised me because
there were Bots but there's also unusual
human activity during this time so I
tracked the five biggest buyers of the
zoocoin and lo and behold this is what I
found Logan was one of the biggest
buyers which is is what you'd expect but
he wasn't the biggest in fact two of the
biggest wallets seemed to be associated
with crypto King himself and here's
where I pause I said wait a second why
did this guy buy more Zoo tokens than
Logan when this is mostly Logan's
project I thought crypto King was a
small part of this team and so to get
more info on this I actually got access
to an internal meeting note from the day
of June 11th which they called Zoo day
and in it we find actually some
interesting information we see that five
Founders bought in they apparently were
quote trading in circles until each
person maxed out but on the list of
buyers and how much they spend are only
four people when we know five people
bought we have Danny Logan's assistant
for 20K Logan Paul for 100k Jeff at 100K
and Eddie at 100K but crypto King is
nowhere to be found and yet on the
blockchain I have him putting in two
hundred thousand dollars worth and this
number by the way seemingly is firmed in
a conversation I had with crypto King
where he said my 200k investment and the
reason this is important is because it
does imply that something Shady was
going on the day of the stealth launch
because crypto King had a relatively
small role in this whole project he was
the advisor but it wasn't that big of a
deal like you can see from the internal
meeting notes they have a breakdown of
who's getting what in terms of founder
tokens and like Logan Paul's getting 51
percent Eddie's getting 30 percent
Jeff's getting 10 Jake's only getting
five percent of tokens but he has the
most of these like stealth launch tokens
which makes no sense and it got me
thinking that maybe what explains this
suspicious Behavior around like oh don't
worry about who was buying at the time
of the launch maybe that's explained
because perhaps no one knew that he was
buying up large parts of the token
Supply maybe he was buying it to sell
later now of course that's speculation
so that's why I confronted crypto King
on all of this but before we get to that
call let's address the elephant in the
room Logan didn't accuse crypto king of
being a scam it was the other way around
crypto King told Logan Paul he was a
scamer and the question is why well to
answer that we have to go from June the
stealth launch date to September 1st the
official launch date of crypto Zoo
September 1st cryptozoo.com now the day
of the launch was a bit strange because
you might think well they already have a
token right but the first thing they did
was actually create a new Zoo token with
a different code but the same name and
they actually airdropped all the holders
of the first Zoo token with an identical
amount of those coins on the second Zoo
token so you might be wondering why did
they do that well maybe it's the change
the smart contract but maybe it's
because of what they did do they
blacklisted some of the holders in other
words they didn't airdrop to everyone
including Jake the crypto King they
excluded his wallets so it couldn't get
these Zoo coins Jake texts the group
about this the next day saying quote the
zoo team made a major error this weekend
they chose not to communicate mint a new
token and airdrop it to whatever wallets
they determined fit this decision came
from Eddie and Logan and I had no part
in it 11 250 wallets before the airdrop
under 11 000 after they chose to
Blacklist and ban over 200 wallets now
who those wallets are I have no idea but
he continues quote as a Founder like
Logan Jeff Eddie and Danny I had
purchased a large quantity of tokens
five plus of my wallets had been
blacklisted from the original team's
buys now I don't know why he had five
five plus while it's there but okay okay
he says 80 plus billion Zoo tokens were
confiscated from me to date without any
communication so wow that's why crypto
King accused Logan of stealing from him
or scamming it's because he was frozen
out of a lot of his wallets then we get
to the text you guys all know he says
Logan you stole 40 million dollars
you're a scammer you're a con artist all
that stuff you betrayed your community
the reality is you aren't that guy and
Logan responds oh Jake trust me bro I am
that guy Q In the Arms of an Angel and
look I mean what do we make of this well
I I don't know I can't root for either
of these guys because it sounds like
Logan stabbed him in the back but it
sounds like crypto King may have stabbed
him in the back in the first place right
uh because it does appear like he bought
tokens that maybe everyone didn't know
about so I'm really not a fan of anyone
in this situation and by the way but
this whole thing was structured so
misleadingly from the beginning I I have
to talk to you a bit about it because
you might think that these tokens were
the only tokens they had but it's not
even true in the distribution section of
Zoo's white paper they say there's two
trillion tokens and a quarter of that
are allocated to development marketing
and Founders those aren't even the
tokens we're talking about right now
because they claim that those tokens
were locked up for six months and then
afterwards ten percent was unlocked
every month and if that's true there
would be no reason for these funds to be
blacklisted right why would you
blacklist something that would be locked
up and the answer is because well the
founders had more than one set of tokens
not only did they supposedly have these
founder tokens that were locked up and
couldn't be sold these stealth launch
tokens were different from that it's
like a whole different thing and the
tokens that they bought that all of
these guys bought they could sell it
basically anytime because they weren't
locked up which is a massive problem and
this fact was explicitly laid out in
their meeting notes with only one rule
they say quote no selling until 200
million dollar market cap and don't
impact the market more than three
percent and not impact the market more
than 10 percent in a day and by the way
like this is basically conspiracy to
manipulate a market you know they're
literally having Insider rules for how
to sell but we're gonna not even we're
gonna look past that right because these
rules eventually kind of changed a text
from Logan's manager Jeff Levin came to
the group chat Zoo Founders saying guys
new and absolute rules no one is to sell
or transfer any Zoo Logan's gonna make
the call when we can make moves and
Logan replies your tokens do not leave
your wallet this is a game now that all
sounds well and good don't sell your
tokens don't sell your tokens but the
reality was I mean they're just kind of
trusting each other because these tokens
that they're talking about they're
unlocked they're not locked up and they
could sell it at any time and I guess
the question on my mind is is that why
crypto Kings tokens were blacklisted
because they thought he would sell or
maybe it's just the fact they found out
he bought and they didn't know about all
those tokens it's honestly hard to say
without knowing more evidence and this
is where we're going to jump into the
blockchain now
attract the wallets of the entire team
and identified the largest seller of zoo
in the team and it wasn't Jeff
it wasn't Danny it wasn't even Logan it
was crypto King crypto King sold by my
calculations millions of dollars and I
know what you're thinking how's that
possible right I thought his tokens were
blacklisted the day of the official
launch how could he sell that much well
the answer is that not all of his tokens
were blacklisted he had even more tokens
behind the scenes and what's worse the
cryptozer team actually gave him back a
lot of his blacklisted tokens which I
guess you can see as a good thing or a
bad thing because he then turned around
and sold those tokens right and from my
blockchain analysis across his
blacklisted tokens he got back and the
tokens that he had squirreled away the
whole time he ended up making six
million dollars he did this by sending
out tokens from these larger wallets to
dozens of smaller wallets selling it and
then sending the money to final Cash Out
wallets so I use those final wallets to
calculate the amount he made now I know
look it's a lot to accuse someone of
selling six million dollars in a project
that doesn't even work it's a giant scam
so I wanted to give him a chance to
defend himself so I got on a call with
crypto King and here's what he said when
I finally revealed that I knew he had
sold
iers
100 it sounds like your biggest issue
with me is that I sold
if that's your biggest issue with me
that's the truth wow that is a big
admission selling tokens for a project
that you're an advisor on when the
project has never been delivered
although crypto King insists that it
wasn't six million dollars and he wasn't
trying to rug a project in fact you know
really he might be the one who got
screwed over in all of this
which bet I'll be able to show you that
I was
will be able to show you
five percent
um holder of the zoo token
I was promised to be given over the
three month period was never given I can
also show you that I was Frozen Adam was
never given the 15 billion tokens back
that I paid for
okay I'll show you all of those things
on the record and then you can also say
that I did sell which is also true yep
as long as it's accompanied with he was
a Founder That was supposed to be even
five percent of the project and was
never given the token or paid worked for
almost a year on the project as long as
that goes in with it then at least that
tells my side of the story so people
understand that it's not like I was
trying to run a project it's like I put
250 000 into a project plus six months
of time and the founder never did
anything he said he was going to do and
then hired a bunch of devs that didn't
do what they were going to do and every
time I gave advice the advice was I was
supposed to pop off so
it can be
that soy or it can be he sold all this
amount and he got in early well yeah
that's like one percent
incredible he sounds like he views
himself as the victim or at least like
he got screwed too which just has to win
the gold medal for me for mental
gymnastics because I mean he literally
had put two hundred thousand dollars
into this and he says he made millions
of dollars even if you take him at his
word that he didn't make the full six
million he admits to me later that it
might be a pretty close guess he tells
me via text quote I don't care if you
tell people I sold a few million and
leave it at that well okay six million
dollars a few million dollars it's
millions of dollars right millions of
dollars when you only put in 200 000
into a project that's never been
delivered doesn't work scammed people
out of their money how is he saying he's
the one who's in the wrong well in his
view what he did was not wrong it might
have been arguably unethical but it
wasn't illegal and what Logan did well
that was illegal you can say the timing
was bad
but the reality is I bought tokens open
market been sold the open market so
there was nothing illegal about that
are people the rest that Logan did made
wrong and illegal now what do I think of
all this finger pointing well I think
it's pretty wild try to make yourself
look like the lesser of two evils when
you made millions of dollars and
investors lost Millions I just do now at
the same time I want to be fair to
crypto King he's not the only one who
sold here but I also have to say not
everyone from the founders did sell for
example Jeff Logan's manager to my
knowledge never sold neither did Logan
Paul which was a huge surprise all their
walls that I tracked you know held on to
their tokens which is good and to their
credit for a game that doesn't work but
you know who did sell Eddie Ibanez the
guy who didn't pay the initial devs the
supposed MIT orphan yeah from what I
could see his initial wallet got a ton
of zoo sent it to a bunch of smaller
wallets and then sold off kind of like
crypto King and for my calculations he
made about 1.7 million dollars now I
have to tell you that like Jake I tried
to confront him and give him the
opportunity to defend himself but he
never replied to my emails or my phone
calls and we're just gonna have to leave
it there but we're not done with the
money just yet because we still need to
talk about the X remember we talked
about how they profited from zoocoin but
they also made Millions from X according
to their own internal mating notes they
plan to make about three million dollars
selling these eggs for 0.1 each a piece
and that's not far from what I
calculated they actually did make which
was about 2.5 million dollars in the
meeting notes they say they're gonna
clear expenses and then do payouts but
pay out who they don't say and these
expenses are referencing in earlier
notes suggesting Eddie and Logan had
both spent three hundred thousand
dollars each which I'll say is not a
million dollars but okay we'll we'll
give it to them right so they got paid
back their six hundred thousand but
where does the rest of the money go well
on the ethereum side there's one payout
for 364 000 to one wallet and another
million dollars to another both are
coinbase addresses so we don't know who
exactly that is but clearly someone on
the team made a lot of money from these
uh nft egg sales that do not work and on
the binance smart chain side where they
also made money selling eggs the zoo
that was spent was supposed to be set
aside for 50 to be burned which they did
but the other 50 was supposed to be
allocated for wildlife Charities and
crypto Zoo development now neither seems
to have happened because all the money
is in a wallet that the team still
controls so they're open questions about
you know where that money is going to go
and where the ethereum money went did it
go to Jake did it go to Logan did it go
to Jeff did he go to Eddie we don't know
but what I know for sure is that no one
was innocent although there are
certainly shades of guilt you can argue
about because of course not everyone did
sell you could look at that as the most
important thing Logan Paul didn't sell
Jeff Logan's manager didn't sell but
does that make them innocent well I
don't think so because they never built
a game they promised people Logan Paul
specifically got millions of dollars
spent on this game on the promise of the
technology that he never built that his
team never built and he never addressed
the failure except to blame his
developers who weren't paid and you
could say he promised to work backwards
to fix it but then never did but at the
same time it's clearly not just Logan's
fault either because they're major team
issues right you've got Eddie selling
millions of dollars of zoo and then
allegedly not paying developers you've
got Jeff who was warned about Eddie who
kept him on the team anyways and then
after they fired Eddie seems to also
have failed to pay developers on time
and then you've got crypto King himself
who sold the most but claims he was the
guy who was scammed which is the
stupidest thing I've ever heard it's
just like Avengers Assemble for the
worst possible team you can imagine to
build a crypto gang and so
unsurprisingly it turns out a lot of
these guys backstabbed each other and so
finding a way to wrap this up was
difficult because it's hard to assign
exact proportions of blame because if
you focus on any one person you kind of
Miss why this project failed cryptozoo
at the end of the day did not fail
because the price went too low cryptos
who failed because they never built a
functioning game that they promised
really the number one problem even
bigger than people selling millions of
dollars of tokens was that they never
paid the developers on time as boring as
that is and as a result the investors
not only got rugged for millions of
dollars which is a problem but they just
didn't get the core thing they had
bought from the beginning which was not
a crypto project but something different
I'm excited to watch uh to launch my
game you keep using out and you just did
it again you keep using a word there
game
you're not using like a project it's a
game it's a game it's a really fun game
that makes you money that's it that to
me is the biggest scam in all of this
yes it's a huge problem people stole
millions of dollars but it's a symptom
of the larger issue which is people
didn't actually care about the game or
this whatever you want to call it they
just cared about the money and this is
ultimately what happens when you have an
influencer LARPing as a businessman it's
what happens when you have a liar
LARPing as a developer and it's what
happens when you have a shady crypto
Guru LARPing as a crypto King you end up
with a mess and in my personal opinion a
fraud as well and now that this thing
blew up in their faces these four seem
to be dodging accountability faster than
SBF Dodges calls with me because I have
reached out to everyone involved I've
tried to get all of their statements on
things so far no one has taken
accountability or offered to refund the
victims at all they're all hiding
pretending these victims don't even
exist but they do exist and throughout
my investigations they've been the
heartbeat of this whole thing so I
decided to close this investigations in
a bit of a unique way rather than me
deciding who's to blame or me deciding
what you should think I want to give
them the last word everyone everyone's
to blame uh Logan in the sense of his
people management is his projects he
still made these promises to people I
think everyone it is to blame including
Logan Paul of course because he was the
the one in charge of this and he was
responsible for all the all of this mess
that everybody has a big part and a
massive massive cross to bear each one
of them scammed the project in their own
way and then and then off after the
sunset they went it was his job to check
the team to make sure that everyone is
working together to make sure that he is
giving the funds of the people that put
it into his project under his name to
people that he actually trusts so in my
opinion if the team failed to perform
that Logan Paul to blame the community
is destroyed
people is angry they just want their
money back they just want their normal
lives back reimburse reimburse those
loyal fans that they have or how to
rebuild the project actually deliver on
the projects for those who are so
holding their eggs like I am for those
holding the zoo coins so maybe they
could just deliberate what they promised
and that would give some Redemption to
this Fiasco does not said a word
that's that's that's a that's as bad or
almost as bad as taking the money it's
the not coming out and just being a man
about it at least we deserve to know
what was happening behind the scenes
while we were waiting for almost a year
and a half the fact that we're hearing
this information not from Logan Paul but
from pretty much an investigator it
really says a lot what did this loss
mean to me it meant a lot not just
personally because I lost quite a lot of
money my kid and also my my wife were
invested it was like telling a kid that
Santa doesn't exist or something like
that because she really believed in all
that game she really believed in Logan
Paul kids look up to that kind of people
so it was some kind of broken dream my
mother got my mum was a bastard my
sister was also invested so I mean my
daughter even had a couple of the the
eggs and animals which the loss for them
hurts the most because obviously it's
just not nice to do for somebody to win
somebody has to lose that's a gamble you
take whether you get into crypto or not
I got in knowing that I could lose
which is fun that's on me but I thought
if I lost something it would be because
I sold at the wrong time
or the game didn't earn as much as I
thought it would and therefore my things
weren't as valuable but I never you
never go into it thinking it's not not
something that they're going to just
sell out from underneath you because
they could make so much more if they
actually delivered on what they said
even if they delivered on close to what
they said and that's the thing is you
don't think they're going to rugby
because there was so much money in a
game wallet ultimately at the end the
way I see it is it was fraud Logan could
have could have put out the red flags or
people would stop investing more into it
because people remember people were
still were investing to this project
until the very last minute where the
ship was still just just sinking down
the ocean and people were still putting
their cash into it if I was on a call
with Logan Paul I would ask him where
did his Redemption Arc go I think he was
in a such a good streak going about his
YouTube career and boxing as well and
it's sad to see that ads because of
money once again we have degraded down
to stealing from his viewers what will I
say to Logan Paul and his team if I
could well actually I I could because I
have an nft from from other projects
that gives me the right to see Logan
Paul to meet and greet with him and I
will actually use that right to tell him
this story again show him this video in
front of me and see how he reacts when
he sees that my family my whole family
and my kid are affected with this
situation because I think that's not
human you would think that Logan would
have would have told his fellow
followers his loyal his loyal fans that
hey guys back off red flag things things
are things there's turbulence in the
water no not a single not a single word
nothing whatsoever it's a market
products at children and knowing full
well that his team is made up of people
that he believes
are shady characters yeah he still goes
on Forbes interviews and says the game
the game is great for kids it's gonna
it's gonna be amazing who loves it most
the kids their kids love it our
developers kids all of them cannot stop
playing the game I think that is
inhumane the way that that side of it's
been marketed knowing what's happened
since knowing that all of the people
that were there from the beginning like
all of the guys that I'd speak to on a
daily basis that we've all just got
nothing now ideally I just want to say
I'll see you in court
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]